[Música]
según los estudios hay unos 300.000
nuevos emprendimientos todos los años en
costa rica a pesar de que esto suene
como una gran noticia 78% de estos
emprendimientos ni siquiera va a cumplir
un gancho es peor 60 60 por ciento es el
78 por ciento o sea 124 mil
emprendimientos ni siquiera va a llegar
al tercer o cuarto mes porque porque
resulta que el año pasado el gobierno
viene y nos dice que bajó el desempleo
claro 52 mil mujeres dejaron de buscar
empleo
simplemente se cansaron más aún el año
pasado el gobierno yen y nos dice de que
creció la economía pero en realidad
quienes crecieron fueron los bancos los
bancos crecieron un 20 por ciento sus
ingresos mientras que las pymes que
están en el sector comercio perdieron 11
por ciento su participación en el
mercado
este es un tema que a mí me vela todos
los días y me preocupa todos los días
porque las pymes son muy importantes las
pequeñas y medianas empresas son
empresas que tienen menos de 100
empleados facturan menos de un millón de
dólares al año y ellos mueren el 70 por
ciento de todo el producto interno bruto
70 por ciento de la riqueza que se
genera en costa rica la genera las pymes
70% de este millón 200 mil son
micropymes o sea que tienen entre unas
cinco personas
por qué pasa esto porque democratizamos
el emprendimiento pero nunca
democratizamos la innovación que
significa democratizar algo significa
hacerlo accesible para todos sin
importar su nivel académico su nivel de
ingresos o el lugar donde vivan
por ejemplo el fútbol todos más o menos
sabemos cómo jugar fútbol ocupamos un
balón y ya con eso podemos jugar pero
algo así es lo que empezamos a ver con
el emprendimiento democratizamos el
emprendimiento pero nunca democratizamos
la innovación
lo que pasó y sin ver estos documentos
extensos llamados política pública
generamos programas de capital semilla
fuimos a las escuelas colegios y
universidades y elegimos a todo el mundo
vaya y emprenda pero con ello
democratizamos el fracaso porque porque
ese capital semilla que se le habló a
los programas de desarrollo empresarial
la mayoría van a emprendimientos de bajo
valor agregado porque la política
pública sigue siendo ineficiente y peor
aún a estas escuelas cualidades
university y universidades a las que
fuimos a hablar de ellos les dijimos que
fueran a emprender pero nunca le dijimos
en que nunca les dijimos en cómo
según los estudios muchos que hay está
la situación pyme que hace ministerio
economía todos los años hay varias
decisiones de año el estado de la nación
y el global entrepreneurship monitor que
es un estudio que se hace a nivel
mundial con los mismos los mismos
parámetros de análisis estas tres
fuentes y se lo digo de mi experiencia
también en costa rica no existe una
cultura de la innovación
falta muchísimo bueno ya está la
realidad y con eso hay que trabajar y
eso lo que hay
también me desvela eso todos los días lo
que puedo hacer para cambiar esa
realidad yo yo yo estudié derecho estaba
trabajando en firmas de abogados muy
prestigiosas a nivel nacional con muy
buenos clientes pero
todavía no no me cansaba porque en algún
momento había querido hace algunos años
antes de empezar con la iniciativa en el
2014 había tratado de aprender me va a
costar mucho entonces bueno tal vez esto
de la citó la forma o la herramienta
para poder cambiar las cosas y ahí fue
donde funde costa rica emprende nuestro
objetivo todos los días es democratizar
la innovación una desesperación que
tengo todos los días por tratar de
ayudarle a todas las personas que se
encuentran sin los conocimientos
técnicos sin siquiera y muchas veces y
si quieren estudios de escuela
completados para que se puedan
desarrollar y que puedan tener una
oportunidad de negocio real porque las
pymes en costa rica notan cuando cree
así que lo que pasa
la situación es que hemos podido ayudar
a más de 700 empresas y pymes a nivel
nacional y regional hemos podido
capacitar y presentarnos entre más de
4500 personas y hemos podido desarrollar
iniciativas previas aunque a veces
pierde un poco la esperanza porque es
combatir contra un goliat que significa
la manera de pensar hay que cambiar la
forma de pensar y eso a veces es muy
complicado porque la innovación es algo
que se puede enseñar que se puede
compartir y que se puede desarrollar
pero conlleva trabajo y conlleva mucho
esfuerzo pero bueno hay veces que en los
días que son malos hay una luz de
esperanza y hay alguien que realmente
nos escucha a la hora que le ayudamos
aquí les presento a juana grassi
bellagio lenny y esther ellas son unas
hermanas de tiraran que fundaron una
empresa que lo que hacen son los quillas
bizcochos no sé si ustedes saben ese
bizcocho que ustedes comprenden el
supermercado es 85% huevo
este es 100% maíz y hace no es que la
innovación viene de parte de él del
producto que muchas veces que creemos
que la innovación es necesariamente
productos nuevos sino que nosotros
logramos convencerlos de que la
innovación viniera desde el modelo de
negocio y que cambiaremos la manera en
la cual ellos estaban comercializando
los bizcochos ahí fue cuando fundamos la
bizcochería una empresa que la fecha
cuenta con cinco locales a nivel
nacional
liberia tirarán cañas san ramón y san
josé es una empresa que factura más de
trescientos mil dólares anuales
a todo esto lo que yo digo es que si es
posible emprender
el viernes que venía la madrugada
volando para costa rica me había
preguntando qué es un emprendedor todos
los días parece que nos reafirmamos como
emprendedores es tanta gente que le
reafirma a sí mismo como un emprendedor
cuando no tienen ni idea lo que se trata
de ser un emprendedor el emprendedor es
alguien que es adicto al éxito su droga
es el éxito porque luego luego ese
fracaso
por eso es personal las ciudades no
emprenden porque fracasar es una locura
hay que trabajar 25 horas de las 24
porque el emprendedor sabe que el éxito
llegará tal vez no inmediatamente pero
sí absolutamente y rotundamente
lo más importante de todo eso es que
ustedes tengan un propósito para lograr
generales impacto el mío democratizar la
innovación cuál es el suyo
vayamos que lo vaya descubra no y si no
lo encuentra haga lo inventé se lo crea
lo porque la única forma lo que vamos a
poder cambiar el mundo en un
emprendimiento a la vez porque costa
rica costa rica emprende muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]